it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to the show where i interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
they'll be from politics sport business
entertainment public life or they'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening the war in ukraine has
brought devastation across the country
whole towns have been flattened
thousands of civilians killed and
battles raging but could there be a
glimmer of hope on the horizon
negotiations this week led to russia
saying it will pull back on attacks on
the capital kiev
one man has been on the front line
protecting his city for tarly klitschko
he was once a heavyweight world boxing
champion now he's mayor of kiev and he
has the fight of his life on his hands
he's speaking to me tonight
there's the war of bombs and bullets and
then there's a shadow war of spies lies
and information
one of britain's spymasters the head of
gchq says putin isn't being told the
truth by his security chiefs but who can
we believe i'll be putting those
questions to christopher steele former
british intelligence officer author of
that infamous dossier on donald trump he
has spent his life observing the comings
and goings of russian spies so he should
know what's going on whether he'll tell
us we'll see
also tonight in 2020 the discovery of a
terrifying new virus changed the world
as we know it cities and countries went
into lockdowns but little more than a
year later there were vaccines available
it was a truly stunning achievement led
in britain by a businesswoman none of us
had heard of before but we know her now
it's kate bingham i'll be asking her how
it all unfolded and whether we're
prepared for the next one
let's get straight into our first
interview tonight vitaly klitschko fast
made his name as a champion boxer he
turned to politics in 2005
and became the mayor of the ukrainian
capital kiev in 2014 but he never
imagined he'd be defending his city and
his people from an invasion by the
russian military a little earlier i
spoke to vitali klitschko the mayor of
kiev
vitale first up thank you so much for
sparing some time to talk to us when you
are
in the middle of what you're in
let me start with the military situation
now in kiev putin has advanced on the
city but he's failed to capture it
and nor has he at the moment sought to
flatten it
with shelling and moscow's now saying it
doesn't want to put keefe at military
risk
are we at a stage yet where you feel you
could say that keiv is safe
first of all it's
nobody feel him
safe
in ukraine
if you in ukraine are you sorry in
danger second point
right now the huge battle we talking
right now and listen it's uh explosion
explosion uh it's battle right now north
of the city and east of the city so you
can hear that yeah
outside
yeah i hear right now outside this
explosion
explosion because in uh
uh
erpina
uh
baradianka gastown
right now right now there is fighting is
near to bravarry it's a small city
satellite city of uh kiev
and that's why right now that circle
around
the the the
russian russian
army we moved back
and
they moved
but
still danger and we listen
all day the explosions fatality when the
russians say then that they tell us and
we hear these press conferences where
they say that they are switching
attention away from keeve
uh and they are moving their forces
elsewhere
you don't see evidence of that you don't
believe that's what they're doing
please don't believe russians
this will be biggest mistake
they told it's not we are in the nest
luganza's was not true they told they
don't want to work
against ukraine it's not rude right now
right now the occupation of ukraine the
russian um
russian forces
make
war it's not rude right now it's
russians told they
go away
it's not true the battle is there maybe
some part of
[Music]
forces move to another
side of ukraine but they still around
kiev and vitali i think we've got some
pictures i want to show you some
pictures that we've been seeing
here in the uk i don't know if you can
see them we have one of mario paul this
is mario paul this is from a drone
and then we also have some pictures from
urpin which is not that far
from you when you see these pictures
how does it make you feel
it's
it's painful to see these pictures the
city doesn't exist anymore
the whole
building buildings destroyed the city is
destroyed and uh it was a couple of
months ago it's a great part of our
cities where
uh
very comfortable life and uh it was
privileged to live in a
satellite city to near to kiev right now
the the city not exist anymore right now
we're collecting their their bodies the
people who
are killed from russians tarly when you
when you see those pictures of of of
other parts of ukraine
are you fearful that this could happen
to keeve or do you think that the
russians would not dare
to bomb the capital in that way
i have a feeling
i have a feeling the russians doesn't
have
some
uh
some um
moral protection or i don't know it's
they killing civilians
they
killed children women's
they destroyed marijuana destroyed the
more than 50 percent of buildings in
harkid totally destroyed its apartments
building
they destroyed help of
turin egypt it's
150 kilometers around 100 miles from
kiev and
i guess they can't use any
weapons with talking right now
about the chemical weapons the russians
already use that in syria
and uh
if couple of months ago
somebody tell me is
what i think about the war i will be uh
i i never expect
in the modern time
in europe
we have a
huge war
this war is biggest one after the second
world war
and uh
if couple of months ago i tell it's
impossible
but right now
right now
right now if you if you ask about our
hometown
it's everything possible if we look on
mario and hurricane
just on on life in kiev at the moment
it's hard for us to understand what it's
like there because what we see
is the reports focused on war can you
describe what it's like in kiev at the
moment are you able to go to shops are
cafes open kids go into schools how are
you living at the moment
before the
before the war
just two months ago
one half months ago the population
of
our city
was three and a half million people we
are one of the largest uh city in east
uh europe
uh right now we guesses uh health
population is uh women's children
already left
the majority right now the mans who
ready to defend our city yeah
uh
the life
we it's actually is war destroyed the
logistic
war destroyed the normal life in the
people
and uh right now the
streets is empty it's uh blog post with
web with people uh with uniform
with weapons territorial defense
but uh slowly uh listen uh ukrainian
listen uh the russian forces a little
bit far from keith
but everybody want to get we want to
came back to city it's personal audition
it's
i talk to many people everybody won't
come to back but it's personal decision
of every family is for everyone
but
the
it's personal risk for everyone who come
to kiev we see we have a release an
explosion uh
every day
and uh the risk
to diet is pretty high and that's why my
personal advice for everyone
who want to come please
take a little bit more time
let's see how
situation will be developed in the next
couple of weeks and vitaly your family
you have children you've got three
children
do you see them or have you had to send
them away i mean presumably you are at
risk personally because the russians
have you on their hit list
my brother brothers to give vladimir is
together with me yeah uh
it's uh
i send my mom and vladimir and his
daughter outside of the country it's the
right knowledge uh family it's uh
outside of the country so you haven't
seen
you haven't seen your family for weeks
more than months that's really hard
that's really hard
um
you are on the russia hit list president
zielenski we know about assassination
attempts on him have there been
assassination attempts on you
is everyone in ukraine in danger
everyone every citizens of ukraine right
now in ukraine uh her risk
i come from a military family
my father former officer
uh he's actually
died
and spent his life to defend the people
in ukraine
in uh
by chernobyl
nuclear catastrophe what ukraine have
1986
uh father study me and my brother is big
privilege
i am former soldier also
it's big privilege
for every man
to give his life
as defender of your country
and that's why we are not afraid
nobody wants to die
but
it's our home
it's our hometown
it's our families it's our children we
defend our children we defend the future
we don't want to live in the country in
in soviet union we don't want back to
ussr we don't want to live in the
country with no human rights waste no
press freedom
waste no rules i talking about the
russian federation because they put in
the goal of putin to rebuild russian
empire and
to occupate ukraine and
to rebuild soviet union
we was in susa and we don't back in the
past time and vitali you are clearly
prepared to die for your country i think
you're saying to me if you lose your
life
you are not afraid
nobody want to die
nobody wants to die
i tell you some example
i uh
during the
every day i go to
every districts of our city i stopping
by blog post and civil defense i am very
surprised the people with very peaceful
profession
for example
musician actors
doctors
right now
they stay with uniform they never they
never expect
to take the weapons in the hands but
right now they want to defend his city
hometown
and
we
we always was peaceful nation
is we ukraine is peaceful country we
never was aggressive to anyone but right
now
is the question about our future future
of our children
we have to defend fatality can i ask you
just quickly about
your future putin clearly wants to take
the donbass region and some of the south
of the country
could you live with russia taking some
territory from ukraine in order for
peace
russians right now starting to talk
about
some compromise
what about we talk
i don't know
uh compromise to give the russians
some part of our territory his
compromise
his job
uh the compromise if the russians killed
thousands of ukrainians and right now we
have to find the solution i don't know
what
we talk about what we what we have to
talk about
and that's why
that's why just one wish russians go
away russian soldiers have to go away
from our home country and after that
we're ready to discuss
we understand the russian
army am i stronger than ukrainian is
actually ukrainian soldier ukrainian
army destroyed
meters
about
strongest russian strongest army in the
world
i explain you why
ukrainians so tough because russian
soldiers paid their fighting for the
money
ukrainian soldiers ukrainian citizens
fighting for the future of our children
are you feel the difference between the
money
and the children
and vitali i have one final question for
you then you're clear that you are not
going to
let putin take any ukraine territory
what about president zielenski's
suggestion
uh that ukraine could perhaps
uh
have a compromise at committing to
neutrality and maybe putting that to a
referendum to the people is that
something as the leader of the capital
you could live with
uh first of all i am not involved in
negotiation process between ukraine and
russia
second one we doesn't have the final
document
that why we don't know what we talk
about i i'm i'm not ready to give the
commenter about that
and
also the referendum uh natural status we
was always natural country
we want to be the part of european
family it's our decision we want to be
democratic modern country it's our
decision
and to take away our wish
it's not fair it's we decide and we have
uh
we need to be
someone who would take a decision
regarding regarding negotiation and
referendum i don't know how we make the
referendum in in the war
big part of ukraine right now outside of
the country they
moved
uh they to safety place
uh in during the war we have a lot of
questions and not so many answers for
that
by the way
i'm
let's see the negotiation
document the
let's see
negotiation
letters
what what
make here
both sides enough that we can discuss
about that okay vitaly klitschko thank
you so much for spending some time to
talk to us tonight thank you
thank you
vitaly klitschko there while coming up
after the break we'll get the thoughts
from a former spy christopher steele
[Music]
welcome back the british intelligence
agencies have been watching russia
closely for decades and since the
ukraine war started they've got their
finger on the pulse of the kremlin or at
least that's what they want ours and the
russians to believe only last night the
head of the british intelligence agency
gchq said putin doesn't know what's
going on because his closest colleagues
aren't telling him the truth but is all
of this disinformation my next guest
says no christopher steele thinks
british spies do have a good idea of
what's going on in russia and ukraine
and he should know because for many
years he was one of them he joins me now
chris thanks so much for joining us on
the show before we start to talk about
all things kremlin let's kick off with
vitali klitschko and that interview you
just watched it what did you make of him
thank you for having me on the programme
beth i'm delighted to be here
i think people like vitaly klitschko
will be remembered for decades if not
centuries
as the real heroes of this period of our
history and of ukraine of course
and a remarkable man incredibly brave
living in a city which is under siege
which he's possibly being targeted for
assassination i think we absolutely have
to take our hat off to him he smiled and
didn't answer that question but you
think he would have been targeted for
assassination without doubt i think
originally when this operation was
underwear yes definitely
so a man that really is risking his life
uh every day um let's get on to uh the
kremlin and intelligence so jeremy
fleming the boss of the gchq uh said
putin has made a strategic
miscalculation he said this in a speech
last night launching this invasion he
said his advisors are afraid to tell him
the truth is that your assessment too
i think that's part of the problem that
you have in an authoritarian system
where there is definitely not a premium
on passing bad news and real news back
up to the leadership however i think
there's a more fundamental point here
which is that russia has always had bad
intent in terms of rebuilding its empire
and dominating its neighbors
and it's never had the capabilities to
match that
and i think this big mistake that
putin's made in this situation of all
the mistakes and there are many
is that he believed that russia had the
capability to fulfill its intents
towards ukraine and it doesn't and and
had an ability to do that quickly and
that hasn't happened and i guess my next
question for you
is that that has clearly caused discord
in the kremlin the russian defense
minister vanished with heart problems
what's going on
are they all fighting each other
churchill once said that studying the
kremlin was like looking at bulldogs
fighting under a rug you couldn't quite
see what was going on but you could hear
the growling and the snarling and it is
very much like that and
one of the problems we've got in
assessing russia over the years is that
it's not an open society it is it is a
complex society the leadership is not
uniform it's not monolithic but it is
suppressed and the divisions are kept
behind the scenes
the fsb the russian intelligence
services though presumably they are
leaking information to the ukrainians is
that partly why the ukrainians are
fighting more effectively is that partly
why people like vitali or president
zielenski despite having
uh being on putin's hit list with
mercenaries in the capital that they're
still alive is that what's going on yeah
i think it's important to remember that
ukraine and russia are like england and
scotland or england and ireland and that
many russians are of ukrainian origin
and vice versa they're incredibly close
these people and therefore the sight the
thought of destroying your cousin's
house and home and cities and after all
kiev was the first capital of the
russian state is pretty horrendous to a
lot of russians and i suspect loyalty in
that situation is very complex and
difficult
today you the uk's military chief said
that while he expects the coming weeks
to be difficult that in many ways putin
has lost do you agree with that
assessment
yes i don't see there's a way back for
putin i think this is one of the big
problems that the west is going to face
going forward i don't see how we can
trust putin in any sort of peace deal
that comes now and i don't see how we
can deal with him in terms of normal
business going forward after all the
president of america has called him a
war criminal
if you can't trust putin though in any
peace deal how does it end because
presumably it has to end with some sort
of deal i mean zolensky's talking about
neutrality and a referendum i mean
how does it end if you can't trust
anything he does and you can't negotiate
i think it does end in a deal of some
sort
um but i think that that deal is some
way off
and i think it probably doesn't include
vladimir putin
what do you mean by that chris well i
think he he may well be pushed aside out
of the top leadership or
even possibly assassinated by his own
people
the the point is that that we've gone
over a watershed here i don't believe
there's any way back for putin i can't
believe he can be rehabilitated in the
international community and that's a big
problem for us going forward it also
means he has no incentives to stop
fighting
i think that's true unless of course
they start losing on the ground and one
of the remarkable things about this
situation now is it does look as though
the russian army at least in some areas
is being defeated and just finally on
this
um
tony radekin has said putin failed to
anticipate the unity and cohesion
amongst free nations of the world
are you worried that this western unity
would crack if donald trump returned to
power
in the u.s well that's not an immediate
prospect um actually in this situation
as at least another two to three years
before there's a presidential election
in america it certainly wouldn't help i
mean whatever one thinks of trump he was
much more of an isolationist than other
u.s presidents he questioned nato's
existence and and solidarity and the eu
and all the institutions that stand up
to russia would were put into question
by him
and chris you're a russian expert you've
studied and gathered intelligence on the
kremlin for many years you now run a
private business doing something similar
were you surprised when putin invaded
ukraine
i was surprised at the scale of the
invasion i wasn't surprised that there
was a military operation or a political
operation to recognize the breakaway
republics as independent
but i had calculated others as a
calculator the logistics of this didn't
add up that if you cannot keep down a
population of 43 million people using
only 150 000 troops it doesn't work so
poor intelligence from the russians
i think poor advice i think poor
intelligence in terms of what i think
putin was being told which was that
parts of ukraine would welcome the
russian troops with open arms and there
was a shadow governance structure that
could be brought in to replace the
current government
and you said in your submission to the
2018 this is the intelligence and
security committee uh within parliament
that look at uh matters of national
security you said uh that russia was
becoming more aggressive that it was
moving from an authoritarian to
totalitarian state
and that uh
putin had to be tackled was the west
asleep at the wheel are we partly to
blame
for this
yes we are very largely to blame for it
in my view some of which is perhaps
understandable after 9 11 for example
there was an attempt to draw putin into
an anti-islamist alliance anti-terrorist
alliance that failed but i think
subsequently to that the problem has
been that the west has been naive about
putin and very slow to react to his
rogue state type activity
and on the issue of
how the west has reacted to putin i want
to ask you a bit about the relationship
between the uk and russia
and about oligarchs and money russian
money in london
in the uk for years you were monitoring
russia and the misdeeds of its spies
like murdering people
uh in the uk
and yet you also saw british politicians
and businessmen they go into parties and
holidaying with oligarchs
do you think that the establishment here
let themselves get seduced absolutely i
think there were two things going on
there one is a element of naivety
because many of the russians who come to
london are very urban very convincing
very sort of westernized
they don't represent the real russia if
you like there is a dark side to russia
which not many people understand sadly
i've been studying it for the last 20
years um but i also think in addition to
that
russian money a wall of money that hit
london it wasn't just russian but it was
russian money first i think
sort of set up a lobby a group of
interests who
serviced this elite who the lawyers the
estate agents the pr firms and so on and
it became a pretty important part of our
economy and i suspect also in terms of
investment and so on particularly after
brexit and what have you when we were
looking for other forms of investment in
the country this golden visa scheme
which is now so controversial and in
retrospect was such a bad mistake grows
out of that problem
and there is one person that's
particularly being talked about lately
which is evgeny lebvedev you said an
interview with sky last october with sky
news it was curious mr johnson boris
johnson had enabled the son of a kgb
officer now it's important that i make
it clear lord levitate is a british
citizen has broken no laws has condemned
the war in ukraine and strongly denies
any insinuation he's sympathetic to the
russian government
but
his elevation to the laws has been
controversial would you like to see the
intelligent reports around the decision
to make him a lord and put him into the
house of lords
yes there's a parliamentary procedure
involved here which is quite complicated
and i do understand need for
confidentiality and so on but this is
such a controversial appointment and the
story out there is that it was against
the advice of the security services so i
think it's a pretty exceptional case and
there was a debate in parliament the
other day and i think probably the
outcome of that should be more
transparency about how this decision was
made
you have some experience would you think
that
that has credibility that the security
services would have been anxious
about
this appointment
i think any sort of family member of a
former kgb
officer or a kgb agent and
actually
lebedev is not the only one there are
quite a few former kgb officers who are
quite prominent in britain and in
business here who need to be very
closely looked at and certainly it's
surprising to me that they've managed to
operate in the company's country in the
way that they have well it is now
changing of course with these huge
sanctions against a number
of different people and companies
can i now bring you just to the world of
spies
because
is it fair to say that people are right
not to trust intelligence sources it's
often disinformation you often use
anonymous sources
yet we're all expected to be reverential
about british intelligence do you accept
that you offer us no truth or proof in
anything you say
i think that's an exaggeration clearly
intelligence work is as much an art form
as it is a science
and what you're trying to do in
intelligence work always is to
test out a piece of information
get it from different sources get it
from different types of sources i think
that actually the calling out of this
invasion by western intelligence has
been a remarkable operation and i think
that
the the decision to preempt to make
intelligence public in this situation to
preempt russian activity has
wrong-footed the kremlin quite a lot
that that was interesting wasn't it
because what happened was things like uh
the invasion the planning of it then you
know the threat of chemical weapons
what's happened is western leaders who
would typically keep that all private
have been shouting about it and making
it public what's the tactic of doing
that
it's the information warfare i mean the
reason that intelligence often isn't
made public is obviously because of the
need to protect sources and techniques
and every time you make a piece of
intelligence public you are taking
certain risks in that regard however in
this situation where you're dealing with
strategic threat the invasion of a
european country by russia the decision
was obviously taken that that risk was
worth taking and i think it's paid off
but it's fair to say as well that
british intelligence officers would also
deal in disinformation as russians would
right
it depends how what you're talking about
i mean if you're saying that we should
be
spreading this information to russian
troops on the battlefield in ukraine
probably yes if you're talking about
disinformation about our own society
obviously not
and chris how does this end you you've
said that you
think that putin there's no way back for
him that there would have to be some
sort of regime change
in russia although how that could happen
still pretty opaque
klitschko said in that interview
that he was worried or he warned europe
the rest of europe
uh that there is a danger that this
tips into a wider european
war
do you agree with that are you fearful
about that
yes i think
people talk in terms of this being like
munich in 1938 1939
it's probably equally
threatening in terms of 1914 where we
sort of slipped into war by various
mistakes and smaller countries provoking
bigger countries and so on so there's
always a risk that something like this
can spread and you know the polls are
very robust they've talked about having
ukrainian fighter aircraft uh in their
country or provided from their country
so it's very important that nato remains
united
everyone sticks to the same script
everyone sticks to the same rules about
this in order to prevent this conflict
spreading okay chris i've got more
questions for you but i have run out of
time as ever thank you so much
for joining us
on the show well look stay with us
coming up next the former head of the uk
vaccine task force dame kate bingham
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the pandemic changed our
world as we know it we were told by the
government time and again that the only
way out of some of the most draconian
restrictions ever seen in this country
during peace time was through a vaccine
my next guest was working as the head of
the uk vaccine task force in 2020
securing the jabs that was still in
development and setting up a plan that
would make the uk a leader in vaccine
roll out earlier i spoke to dame kate
bingham
dame kate your task doing the vaccine
task force was to source a vaccine scale
up capacity
build capability in vaccine development
then make for the provision of
international distribution and then
strengthen the uk's capability for
resilience for future pandemics which
actually sounds exhausting just reading
it all out
um there's so much to talk about about
that and also about uh future proofing
against pandemics but
if we kick off with
what you did in the vaccine task force
what was the single biggest
lesson you learnt in that whole process
i mean the single biggest lesson was
probably getting the right team together
and having a clear mandate and
empowering the team to actually do the
work that we need to do because
everything was in a rush because every
day we took more people were going to
die so
the first thing we did was to actually
put together the experts from industry
together with the experts from
government and agree this is the
strategy and this is how we're going to
do it and because there was so much
uncertainty what we did is put in place
a very uh focused set of meetings three
times a week so that we at least had a
framework with which to actually start
communicating what we were doing and
talking about progress so getting that
team together
uh getting a diverse team together
actually so we had plenty of women
who brought real depth of skills
alongside
the men we had in the team
in terms of learning diversity of skills
people thinking backgrounds
made for a really effective team and
without the team this couldn't have
happened now it was a success it's
transformed everyone's lives that
the vaccine rollout worked and the
vaccine was found
but when you were contemplating this at
the beginning
did it occur to you that you were most
likely going to fail i knew it was most
likely to fail
and there were so many reasons why i was
likely to fail the first thing was that
we had no vaccine against any human
coronavirus so we had no template or
playbook to follow the second thing was
that vaccines historically take five to
ten years to develop the quickest was at
four years and that was done for 50
years ago
and we didn't know anything about this
new virus so we had so many reasons to
be skeptical that this was possible and
to be able to
go from sequence to start vaccinating
people in a year
which is what we did was not what we
expected to do at the beginning because
we knew that most vaccines fail
you're obviously a very successful
person was there a moment you thought
this is kamikaze i'm setting myself up
for failure how did it come about that
you
took the helm
the reason i was asked was because
patrick valance
had set up an expert advisory group to
advise the government on the procurement
and identification and procurement of
vaccines um and he then invited me to
join that advisory group and my job for
the last 30 years has been to develop
novel
drugs to treat unmet diseases and so
when patrick then asked me to join the
expert group i
asked him why since i don't know
anything about vaccines
and he said but you understand the small
company uh landscape and it's that
innovation landscape which is actually
where the bulk of the vaccines have come
from so he brought you in because he
knew you from industry
but then the prime minister personally
called you up correct and asked you to
do it everything is done by text so you
get a text saying can you speak so i
first got a text from matt saying could
i speak i then spoke to him and he then
said the prime minister had asked him to
ask me to do it i then said i want 24
hours to think about it and 24 hours
later i went back with a list of
conditions on the the basis of which i
would do it and having established that
then the pm called me and that was to
seal the deal then really that was to
basically accept the conditions which
was six months that i reported to
the pm that i would have a quick
decision-making process
um that i could hire my own team to be
able to get on and do it i mean did you
have this phone you thought i am
i'm going to fact this is awful i've
been asked to do something i've got to
do it because it's the pm's ask me in
the middle of a pandemic
and i don't know if i can do it so
absolutely i had that entire imposter
syndrome you know i can't do it and i'm
not the right person um and that was
because i've not a vaccine expert and
the so but while i do therapeutics so
what i'm very familiar with is how do
you develop new drugs and in patients
but those are for patients
who have a disease putting
something into people who are healthy
volunteers is just a little bit
different prophylactic vaccines and so
when i was called
i hooked on the vaccine as being this is
what they're wanting me for but actually
they're not what they want is someone
who can do basically what venture
capitalists do which is put teams
together build plans uh figure out
milestone-based
events which you which are key to
actually the success of the development
of of the
whether it's the therapeutic or a
vaccine and so there's lots of the style
of how venture capitalists work is what
was needed here and the venture
capitalist mindset
and then whitehall
they're kind of different culturally
different very different things
you presumably met quite a lot of
resistance that's my first question then
my second question on this is that
is the venture capitalist mindset only
applicable in
the public sector when it's an emergency
situation
so two questions on the did i meet
resistance not really is the answer so i
had uh absolute uh support and
cooperation from the pm and actually if
you've got that top level leadership it
is incredibly helpful right and
i established upfront that we were going
to be putting
money at risk without knowing if any of
these vaccines would work so it's what
the what
whitehall calls no regrets funding
and so we'd establish the principle that
if we wanted a vaccine we were going to
have to put money up front there was a
lot of scrutiny around you the fact that
you were married to a treasury minister
you know you know there's all these
sorts of this charge about being part of
the chamocracy if you like and there you
are doing this incredibly hard job uh
for and not being paid to do it did you
ever have moments when that happened
thinking i've put myself i've been asked
to do i've stepped up to do it and now
i'm being publicly criticized you didn't
really have a right of reply did you
just sometimes say why have i bothered
to like why the hell am i doing it did
it annoy you of course it annoyed me um
the challenge is um this all happened um
just only a few weeks before i was due
to finish and by then we'd put it all in
place had all that happened early on
um it might well we might well have
ended up in a different place but you
might have walked you mean
oh it just may not we never would have
achieved what we achieved the advice i
got um was incredibly clear which is
take your ego out of this focus on what
you're doing and and move on because
this will all pass
yeah of course it did
it's very bizarre when you when you're
not used to being in that world to have
a whole lot of people say a whole lot of
lies about you and you can't respond
i mean it's really bizarre
lily allen has a great song and so i
used to go uh running we're in the dark
with a head torch on listening to lily
allen and it was great and i'm not going
to say the name of the song in people
i'd be off to guess it yeah
i watched your romana's lecture you gave
it in oxford in 2021
and you spoke about how your father your
late father lord bingham
had been honored given that lecture
19 was it 19 years before you gave yours
or 18 it was one of the other
and and you talked about
you you spoke about how he talked about
um the vulnerability of personal freedom
in times of crisis
and then i saw
you you paused um
and you you needed to kind of collect
yourself and you
when you spoke about your dad what was
what was in your mind at that moment um
i just i caught mum's eye who was
sitting in the front row and you know i
practiced it and i'd said it so many
times so it wasn't as if i was saying it
for the first time but then seeing mum
sitting there that's what absolutely uh
triggered me so i don't have to say just
stop and it was actually i mean it was
actually a lovely moment you know
it wasn't absolutely but it was
unexpected for me but well incredible
that you followed your dad as well and
one mother question about him as i said
he was widely regarded as the greatest
lawyer of his generation one of the most
seniors justices in
the land um how how did he influence you
your dad uh
not to go into the law
so i went and did
i mean i was very keen uh i think to
carve my own path and that's why i ended
up in science so nobody else in my
family does science uh nobody else does
sort of small business e innovation risk
that sort of thing so i think i'm just a
you know
maverick
right let's quickly get on to future
pandemics covered is it over what we
know is we are we had delta
variant that was really very serious
last year we're now in the middle of
omicron
this could continue to
evolve um an outcome you know new
variants could out compete the question
is will it ultimately end up as a
seasonal flu type
disease and we hope that is where it
will end up so that there's sufficient
levels of immunity that we won't have
this well kate i mean patrick valance
when i've gone to the press conferences
he has talked about this transition from
pandemic to endemic yeah or epidemic
endemic endemic um
where it does become like the seasonal
flu but you you say it's still not clear
i don't think it's quite there yet right
um and
and so to the extent i mean the stat we
heard this morning was ten percent of of
children in the uk have coveted right
now so that is still a vast level of
viral transmission and presence in the
in in the country so we just don't know
yet what the remaining drift and
mutations could be
is the government ready to scale up in
the way it did before
should another virus come along
that really threatens
the the public well a lot of the scale
up has been done so part of what our job
was in 2020 was to put those
plans in place so we um
uh basically took the existing ecosystem
for vaccine manufacturing and scale up
um and nine different sites around the
country we have now
uh funded to scale up into much more
significant
capability so we've got a lot more
capability here now you talked about
having someone in government that's
responsible for this yes i mean i think
we should be treating it like we treat
defense because you know we're much more
likely to get a another serious pandemic
than we are to be invaded by somebody
yes but really serious not just a
cabinet minister yeah absolutely okay
and it needs to be somebody ideally um
uh that comes in i think that needs to
have that private sector experience have
you suggested that's the pm yeah yeah of
course and what did he say oh they you
know they'll take all those suggestions
well ultimately
transpires i don't know
do you think
that we have finally killed the
stereotype
that science is a boy's subject i mean
there's a lot of very very punchy women
who were absolutely instrumental in
in the whole initial covid response
no i don't and i think it's partly
because
we don't
uh teach our kids in school as to what
the what you can do in science so people
i still think think of scientists as
being you know men in white coats well
actually it's not that if you think
about what we're dealing with in
technology whether it's phone apps or
cyber security or how do you deal with
climate change and as soon as you start
saying well all of those are underpin
underpinned by scientific understanding
actually that's what's going to get
people excited because these new you
know younger people now they absolutely
want to help um save the world do you
think it's a coincidence that the people
heavily involved in
um
this vaccine were women
i think women are very good at problem
solving and just getting on with it as
you did well look thank you so much
thanks kate for talking to me i
appreciate it pleasure thanks for having
me
well that's all for today's show thank
you to all our guests fatali klitschko
christopher steele and dame kate bingham
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
beth rigby interviews podcast a new
episode will be available later tonight
each week i take a look at the
highlights of the interviews and there's
some extra behind the bits scenes start
setting too
that's on the sky news app or wherever
you get your podcast